Let's now take a look at the anatomy of an HTTP response. A response
includes a status line, which includes the
HTTP version and a response code, whether response
code may indicate a number of possible
outcomes. 100 response codes are typically informational and
200s indicate success. So an example, 200
response code is a common server response that
indicates okay. 300 response codes indicate redirection.
For example, a 301 response code indicates
that the page has moved permanently. 400s are errors, a well known one being 404
which is not found, and 500s indicate
server errors. Other headers, include the location, which
may be used for redirection. A server
which indicates server software. Allow which indicates the
HTTP methods that are allowed such as
get, head and so forth. Content-encoding, which
describes how the content is encoded. For
example, if it's compressed. Content length, which indicates,
how long the content is in terms of bytes. Expires which indicates, how long the
content can be cached. And last-modified, which
indicates the last time the page was modified.